it was hard to tell who was more excited
Lula da Silva or his supporters a day
out of prison the former president
addressed a crowd that was thrilled to
have him back Lula represents the whole
dream of the Brazilian people not only
mine not only my families but millions
of families in Brazil he laid out an
ambitious agenda I want to build this
country back up to make it as happy as
it was when we governed it my dream
isn't to solve my problems today I'm a
guy that doesn't have a job Lula served
eight years as president ending in 2011
he was vastly popular overseeing a
leftist agenda that saw strong economic
growth and a reduction in inequality but
his term was dogged by corruption
allegations he's just one of dozens of
senior officials to have gone to jail in
recent years at anti Lula rallies in
cities across Brazil those corruption
allegations were front and center
he was the country's president he
governed and he could have transformed
it into a great one and he achieved the
opposite he caused everything to go
under stealing public money and for that
he should be imprisoned and Brazil's far
right president Jair balsa Niro reacted
harshly to his release the majority of
Brazilian people are honest workers we
don't want to have anything to do with a
prison inmate he's free but he still has
all his crimes on his back
[Applause]
Fernau Lula's riding high but he could
be jailed again if he does not win the
remaining appeals against his sentence